what up everybody it's your boy adam ak
here for anime uproar and welcome to
another episode of rant cafe episode 44
the craziest long ass running podcast on
a train continues every week Thursday
5:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time today
we're gonna be discussing the best ships
in anime you guys and I'm with me right
now
I have enemy recon I have soul maka and
also the anime dude what's up guys
yo yo yo yo you guys already know what's
goin down for this one we're gonna
discuss the best anime ships you know
like Space Battleship Yamato that type
of stuff so get your engineering skills
out we're gonna be talking about the
best most 30 ships in anime soul your
favorite ship Oh too many okay I'll have
to go with a very cutesy one and say hey
Ichi x-bow dandy God clearly wasn't
following I say for me it has to be
between you guys oh I'm getting a lot of
people in the chat already talking about
their favorite ships Natsu and Lucy
Ria's and Issei where those people are
we got victory classic Luna classical
music window check oh that's a good one
we have Nina X table cool goddess that
is but yeah so what I would like you
guys do in the chat by all means
participate but give me some reasons to
why you think it's a good [ __ ] because I
want to see some actual reasons they're
not just throwing stuff out there guys
um by the way Sol the people you
mentioned were they from
yeah oh yes I they're from ARMA goddess
or oh my god s if you eat manga yeah
basically he is
guy rather unlucky so then he gets all
his good luck at once
and what happens is he cause a phone and
it goes through to to goddess hotline
and he gets bailed and II to come visit
him and grant him one wish and he's
wishes to have a goddess like her stay
with him forever and it gets granted but
the thing is in goddess talk or terms
that is also a proposal so from then on
basically they're like husband and wife
and it's just it's a beautiful thing
that she'll do anything for him
literally anything for him and you know
she's goddess come on literally she's a
goddess you can't go wrong with that can
you really I suppose that's a pretty
it's pretty good to her god that's why
food if they do everything for you
unless that white food is hot then
you're in trouble
yeah we got we got a lot of my near
academia shipping going on I'm seeing
vodka and midoriya but we have some
materia X to you shippers as well here
guys so that's an interesting one
there's there's a rivalry between sue
you and Baraka for me Toria in the chat
we also Jonathan Essex saying any an
Armin from attack on thing that's an
interesting one I don't know about that
obviously peerless opinion says Lelouch
xc2 I think that's one of the my
favorite ships of all time absolutely
and I think that's Canon I don't care
what anyone says
Jonathan has historia in your mirror
mmm-hmm yeah yeah coogo exude anime
bromo anime guy tell me you've been
making a lot of romantic aster videos on
your channel by the way like to enemy do
these channels in the description tell
me my dude what are you some of your
favorite two ships uh
they have to be from the same series or
no well I assume so yes like they have
to be characters that interact with each
other you know anything like Comi 9x
Ria's Gremory or something we don't want
crack ships no cross ships from the same
series I don't know that's actually kind
of a tough one if you're going from Co
enokitake which is the channel what I do
most of my channel I really do like uh
we know Juanita that's good yeah oh no
okay that's interesting
all right why not why do we know why
does it have to be her huh just because
I found that her journey is a very
similar to his parallels is in a lot of
ways they have so much in common
whereas Nikki Mia I feel like a lot of
them being together it's just him
feeling bad mm-hmm like they end up do
getting along but there's just not as
much there I will say guys that we have
a lot of Luffy x-bow Hancock one piece
here at one piece guy and rocks is
really trolling us he's like Cory X
Raven I have to give him props for that
one we have on who say incest which is
our discord server ship one of our
famous discord service ships if you want
to check out our difficulty the link is
in the description it's always crazy
over there oh yeah someone mentioned
earlier Mobile X Todoroki yeah I like
that [ __ ] yeah yeah that's a good
surprise that I'm quite disappointed
nobody mentioned my favorite ship of all
time caster for life says Android 18 and
krillen
and yeah I love that sure if it was an
unexpected one back in Dragon Ball Z but
I think that's a really interesting ship
and I
what about you guys yeah glad my boy
Crillon finally got some yeah yeah he's
better than the heartache he got from
Marin girl and Jesus yeah I got some
love nothing but dirty yeah yeah I guess
the lot of drinkable super he gets all
of either don't worry
what is yum Jack does youngish actually
have a ship do bonus he doesn't he
doesn't go with anyone with Jean tags
all my is a good ship too because it's
like too soon there is yeah just two
tuners clashing and it is a fun we have
boruto ex Selena
I don't watch boat it though so I'm not
sure motor to is Naruto's bar to is some
of that is asked is daughter
kaneki extol cast so we have some pokey
oh cool shipping are we next wrong
course I I have to say Richard fun of
course I know about Horomia come on holy
Mia of course it's a beautiful ship no
no no no he knows I'm talking about holy
me is he say it's name of the manga its
name remind you so it's half of her was
her name and like part of his name
because his name is MIA Maura and she's
Horry
so it's Horomia yeah but it's a good
it's really it's a it's really beautiful
it did get an anime actually it got a
three or four part OVA I guess we can
count that one as well let's use
documented xqp mia right there just kind
of breaks my heart like the ash vs.
misty from Nick victory yeah other
classic Inuyasha X cargo man that's
another classic right name what on
Phillies were right
not too fired up is heartbroken about
Ichigo exit houki are not happening oh
well well yeah we probably should even
talk about bleach because usually under
this Corvis chata soon as bleach is
mentioned soul ends up having an
eight-hour conversation with a bunch of
you [ __ ] man I don't even watch bleach
which like bleach like arguing about it
you clearly yeah I like to hang on stuff
let's not open this discussion otherwise
people will get into it I guess there's
two ships I
I want to say that some people may know
of or some people may not is Carol X
which you call from kids on a slope
never watched it like which character
that like the main girl and bun you know
bun the boy with the glasses yeah yeah
yeah yeah him and the girl who's that
owns the house record why didn't he just
like anything was yeah I know I mean it
yeah the manga does yeah like I showed
you those pages in it like you know and
you're not pregnant and stuff so yeah
the manga is a lot better but I do I do
like that ship and it did appear in an
anime so I'm gonna I'm gonna count it
still but with the credit of the manga
so yeah and then there's Teiichi Xu coal
from Tasha Garre or Tommy X amnesia or
dust maiden of an illusion
yeah yeah the ghosts go you come mm-hmm
yeah yeah I like I like that um that
ship is on alright I think it's my turn
you know give out but I'm pretty sure
I've given away yeah well anyways my
favorite ship of all time that's right
you guessed it is Kitty toe X asana from
sa o yo also know
it's the butterfly go on a pig come on
don't like what the butterfly girl the
pig yeah the butterfly go on the pig
from exo world oh how about SUNY and
mocha from Rosario vampire yeah yeah
mocha you know what no I prefer Fergie
the succubus girl likes a good succubus
Rosario vampire though if we were gonna
get into crack ships and we could always
put that purple haired girl
the who's kind of a stalker ice maiden
go yeah yeah yeah I mean she's
definitely a stalker you yeah she have
skulkers together yeah hmm Ram says
rocky but ended up its rocky ex Claire
in claymore yeah I shift that should
have dug hard I wish that anime went on
for longer but I definitely should by
the way I want to tell castor for life
to [ __ ] off
because he said Gina likes calling
earlier and no yeah ANBU says Solex maka
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah I have to support
the ship Robinson oh you see the whole
life is about that ship
my name is that ship yeah by the way
body pillow whoo and I may or may not be
using it in a video
wait did nächsten I know did knocks tell
you about it he told me about it as well
yeah I got it was it was not related to
knocks but he told me about it but it
was not directly related to that however
yeah some stuff I haven't yeah Nux
actually not told me about it no you
said if I was interested and I was like
yeah sure what why yeah sure why he says
they just want some advertisement no and
I was like yeah I'll get myself a rim
buddy
why not it depends you're such a pleb
recon who's on the the pillow animal oh
that would be the surprise that'll be a
reveal better BC - it will be a very
quickly you know but it's all because
it's gonna be used for the video so it's
definitely I'm pretty sure I know who it
is it's Yoko its Yoko yeah Yoko film
logon for sure boy ex-communist ship
yeah that was a good ship while it
lasted for like five minutes that's
another one that breaks my heart
no jeez jeez dooms Minh and whoever she
like has a relationship they die she to
be honest that is why she is not gonna
see comment on the body pillow Subaru's
yeah
Ram RAM no that's a cracker bread oh
damn and you're gonna get some hate for
that one bro how about you can't leave
our boy Deku come on you can you know
from Nikki that guys Yuki em you know
know why not know because I think diary
7 uses were better not the couple was it
six was it seven and six am i beating
seven and six that are you yeah I do
remember but I just prefer you you go
you you can you know don't get me wrong
you know it's a great character
understand yes sir Benny well Yuki is
kind of a [ __ ] character though who
cares we have we have in the Chad C Mon
X Nia from Gurren Lagann yeah that's a
good ship another tragic [ __ ] but we
love it guys talk about his tragic one
wait analysis says animatics
some chick named misty guy I hope you
don't mean mystic anoxia who was on the
screen two weeks ago and then last week
we had a key dearest on the street do so
it's like I ran cafe has gone global
people it's not sim imagined of knucks
just pops in right now and brings
someone over like [ __ ] double for
anime I got something for you that's a
rank affairs all about guys it's both
have a fun chat and doing crazy we we
had some also we had some cool funny
mentions in the chat like anime
community X salt and one of my favorite
humorous ships is always o other Amina X
table code of course is Levi X cleaning
equipment I'm a big fan of that show
paradox paladin said told Maya Xcode to
me from collab no no Tom layout belongs
with Nagisa it is the perfect ship and
the spell cut Pony and what amis cool
you know kill is cool no nothing against
those ladies but totally as specifically
needs to be with Nagi said I want to see
sue no hot against some love for these
from these girls that's fine but told my
ex Nagi stuff forever guys forever so
someone Adina
from chicawa Kino soma soma ex Erina
Zach's fish that's a good one also Ryu
Kapil's so more an eddy nub come on now
I liked was a rock who ex honored era
from mystically even though yeah I won't
spoil it for you anime only fans but you
won't be happy I finished it the ending
was the ending of the anime is different
from the manga by the way what do you
mean the ending of what the second
season of
yeah I didn't think I didn't think
that's the end cuz that was already
covered in the manga and the manga still
goes on more after that [ __ ] do you
expect no unit now good old Rican
doesn't do this thing you call read yeah
I don't know readings for noobs
sometimes yeah I do read subtitles whoa
yeah that's part of it you know I'm
always firing shots at you recon in the
chat but Gilgamesh says Gilgamesh
Campbell no offense
Gilgamesh quite raised you Gilgamesh X
world conquest but by the way for me
personally one ship that I would always
like to have seen happen was Spike xB
Valentine from Cowboy Bebop no I wanted
to see that happen guys spike is too
cool to be came down like that no but he
wanted to be chained down it's just that
the whole thing happened with Julia but
anyways I think loop in X uh Nina is bad
would you call me name well you can't
talk is your new finish watching about
people I think that's about as death in
the main seat and as death and the main
character of a couple the main
character's name was the guy as oh yeah
sue me everyone else keeps throwing all
these tragic ships out there I wanna go
ahead and I'm just loving cousin out so
far enough said - spooky X bleach
definitely - spooky uploaded like a
50-something minute video about bleach
so you best love right there
you know that's love
when you're putting that much work as we
love Luna says call an ex Anna Mac that
is acceptable
I will also accept Anna Mac X the letter
or Anna Mac X albedo or adamak X follows
but I could go on
yeah that's a good idea why don't you
love the audience ship us and see who we
fit with na o you on board an idea
wait what did I worship me with oh yo
just draw [ __ ] scroll up to meet them
Luca said Nina X table X chair fmm
threesome well nobody the joke's on you
because care is female recon X's right
hand does that mean what the [ __ ] does
that mean
you need us to break it down for you
bleep bleep Oh
it only gets class here for you when you
watch that Haven channel you know the
lotion issue yeah need i say any more
[Laughter]
[Music]
someone earlier someone mentioned omega
x soon O'Hara of totally all external
Hara and I feel like toilet sooner I
have like the kind of relationship that
recon it knocks out yeah I mean my
relationship with them is good you don't
be see no heart three context a stall
for yeah I don't mind going with
ourselves even though he's a guy I don't
care okay cool man
recon xpeke oh no I
go for a stole for a tournament people
to be honest well I mean I don't think
that's even a question
I don't think Eco is some cool input
from the chat I have to commend you guys
for that we also had a harem X plot or
hentai Explorer but either way the same
thing I've got a tragic tragic parent I
mean they got married and stuff but it
was tragic and that was a you me X vada
from trouble bits and that was his
pursue calm wife I think I haven't
you've seen that one thanks for spoiling
I've seen Travis oh it's just it's just
like a site or a backstory should I say
within chobits it's not like a current
running story it's a back story yeah
like she was a purse accom then there's
currently does it go who has the same
name that likes him but he keeps on like
backing out of it because he's memory of
his wife that she ended up I don't know
getting a bug so her memories kind of
got wiped and then one time in his
depression he was looking to stand in
front of this uncommon Laurie and she
pushed him out the way and got hit so
yeah Laurie no no Louis the buzz on
Laurie is a truck shipping yuck
yeah how many of these are made me said
look like a truck [ __ ] okay yeah I yeah
and I also there was the the one another
friend hooked up with a teacher right
yes and then she's like well away from
where her husband at it it's a really
funny comedy anime with a lot of like
deep serious yeah yeah yeah some serious
relationships going on yeah yeah even
like the beginning like the guys like a
village boy and then he goes to the city
right so even that culture clash and
stuck it's an interesting I haven't
watched in years cuz I be said older one
but I definitely should re-watch it
how about yeah me and hashiba from has
made in Oh golly
yami-chan
and hoshi baku from Raja Muda nogales
the good ship like that or Ronco I don't
know Richard in the chair just enough of
these tragic things he said Booga
ex-truck sama
oh yeah the truck that almost killed her
Eddie yeah I know the manga I know what
happens in the money people have told me
about it
Eddie dropped an okapi x3 suit I like it
that's a classic classic Shiro says when
the Eckstrom you have no idea what as
well as death and touch me oh is that
some ferret Oh Wendy Wendy yeah one day
they're fighting Peter there's an anime
Romeo and Juliet I don't think there's a
character Wendy there is there a Romeo
in fairy tale every gun no no no yeah
there is
yes to get the girls up in anywheres not
to scoff or scarf a glass who scoff yeah
it's um but yeah is the kid oh yeah it
is very tell Romeo Nguyen do you yeah
come on recon TW Fairy Tail expert I've
only seen like the first 50 episodes I
know I'm sorry I failed you alt well
sorry because we are not a cult
you were just a you know a secret group
of like-minded individuals why don't we
form a guild about that yes a guild
[Laughter]
not ideal but there is a discard
gilgamesh x-saber oh that's an
interesting [ __ ] well cuz you you know
you know Shira in doing [ __ ] with that
we pretend x2 10 light X potato chips on
them haters baby
Jojo X means more like Jojo XK poses
[Laughter]
what gay poses a Mustang AK x Rize
hawkeye Goodwin caster inter max
favorite anime and now he's gonna drop
[ __ ] in from ever yeah I love that yeah
yeah that's a cool one that was a cool
one
yeah Rize is just like like there's very
little fan service in full marks and
brother and there's that there's like
that one image are like Rize topless
with like you see that that big tattoo
on her back and [ __ ] and i'll just like
damn with her hair down for once like I
was like damn it's not a lot of
fanservice but it's just enough next 300
chairs behind him yeah man I got as many
chairs as a Spartans
for the Tokyo ghoul funds toka ex
Kenickie yeah okay and he finally guy on
there's all which is pretty cool whole a
whole chapter dedicated to them getting
it on straight up finally Canon yeah
yeah someone that I forgot to mention
bit more my favorite is a Kraft Lawrence
and holo from spicy wolf oh yeah
Momo Xu Kirito from to love room no no
no no no no that's cool she's cool but
no I know no no no no mom always a
little sister yeah she's the she's the
one who comes up with a harem plan
that's why he she's the best no I think
you EU is the best girl for me in not
you yeah the moles committee go yeah I
know
the only woman a lot of them that
insensibly she's about like you know by
being married having kids raising guys
I prefer mobile because she probably
knows what she's doing in there in her
life helping Yuki with his hair no no no
I'm almost kind of torturing ourselves
so she's saying cuz the thing is she she
loves you ki ha ha only way she sees
that she could get close to you key is
to convince him to have a home and then
she'd be able to be close to me but then
the problem that she has is still she
has to enjoy him being shared with
others alright fine yeah man so we're
talking about this series to love Rouge
has a total of four season I do
recommend you to watch everyone it's my
series doing Joyce really good it's fun
it's fun it's a good fun since alright
mama says Kota X Lucy from elf and Lee
oh man that's that's a good one mate now
what makes you think it's like oh what
she did this but they develop their
character so well so so you might like
this
yushik oh and aku from aho girl let's
not go talk if anything I would say but
I don't know his name the class
president guy and the Yankee girl from
sorry Zuri children I would say the best
we go to classes yeah yeah that's good
so humorous was so humorous you
basically confronted her and she's
trying to like fun and at like oh yeah
you know she gets paid to have sexy
their older men and stuff like that like
it's nothing to her you know if he tries
the nuts for a kiss yeah so he's that oh
wow how much do you judge and she's like
ah 10,000 yen so just pulls it out she's
like what we do with that kind of money
and then he just goes unzip he's totally
like you know he's just like he knows -
like she's chatting rubbish so he's just
like basically like pushing her buttons
which is you know really cool there's
that really sweet caring as well from
that to raise your children
the one where like the girl doesn't have
confidence like gee she doesn't believe
that the guy could actually like her dad
that's another couple that I really like
but again I can't remember their names
darling and MIA from Mossman darling
what you can't even say his name is it
give me talk give me guff you say
curator no no I said Kim Ito he people
is that his name I think so
like what gorgeous go max says double
for anime x4 never world but sadly they
broke up yeah they broke up a long time
ago
his name is Kimmy heat oh oh you're
[ __ ] King heat oh sorry about that
oh yeah commuter Mia Aaron X Mikasa was
mentioned that yeah I shipped them I
think that ship needs to be can and that
needs to happen it's meant to happen
[ __ ] also few people mentioned Ryuji
and taiga from Toradora for sure that's
good about his story effects Armin
history axe Armand no Reiner wishes
right yeah just just marry me damn it
I'm gonna marry her someday
Oh Castro ryuko x mark oh sorry caster
but both Yuko and Sasuke X and Mac I
know shape every time have you seen
gamers this season yes
chickie XK 2 or no nope
Kendall and kata Tendo fan Tendo is
veteran hello Justin always or I would
go for ugly I'll go team kappa yeah yeah
they've been both spending a lot of time
together within the series you know
we'll figure out how the
misunderstandings and [ __ ] so yeah why
not yeah I know I know but for the for
the [ __ ] entire series she thinks
he's been cheating on her oh yeah and
trucks camo Joe panik's college or X
college oh well it's a sensual series
cameras or
[Laughter]
an trucks as the resident comedian guys
it were good Joe X levy fun ferret are I
do you like that parent I understand you
guys are shipping a fairy tale when you
haven't even completed the damn series
yeah yeah not finish this I'll finish
the manga the manga oh you read it manga
so okay the end you supposed to be a
fairy tale fan here's the thing the new
season ain't out yet okay
yes I've already finished it and yeah
that's a difference between your crap so
great when you can soar yet I wonder if
recon will break down - bye guys
the truth is I can't read no I do i do i
do know some Japanese words but no I
can't like say a sentence is fully you
know what you know which word you do
know yes
you know the only one the only word I
know because I'm yeah I liked I liked a
classic from Inuyasha my favorite pen
from Inuyasha was Miroku and Sango I
didn't end up having like three kids or
something later in the show you know the
monk guy in
and yeah the ninja girl when you got
cutting and the giant boomerang thing
yeah yeah them to Android says midnight
and mount ladx him those are his wife
was well I don't know man
I might have to fight you for mountain
lady I'm a pretty big my lady
no one like me what about the snake girl
what about me yeah like the one with
snakes on her head
yeah that's her yeah yeah the one who
does the male 1 yeah did you just say my
lady guru on you I didn't but I wish you
know thanks my lady
yeah for my boy be nothing I'll give up
a mountain lady is my wife mean it is is
just best boy for sure is having him no
cheerleader scene well him nothing like
in the manga so much stuff that he's
does easier to do like in the manga
that's just classic yeah like no better
character I don't know if you guys know
this one have indeed do you guys know
the series a gay no I've heard main guy
icky him and Wingo is really cool he's
like she's more like whoa she's from a
family like a team of like these roller
bladers cuz this this was all about it's
all about like rollerblading and
attaining new heights new skills and
stuff and I think her family team is
called sleeping for us
Solana I like so they're quite like
well-known in it but like they kind of
like I don't know
not exactly wanting to hide in but just
like kind of stopped competing then like
iki starts getting into it he starts
competing and stuff but then sometimes
these salmon problems so then one time
in particular when go turn up yeah
and he needed to disguise herself yeah
before she disguised herself kind of
like Tuxedo Mask but it was like a
swimsuit a school swimsuit with a hat
and like the like the same I maskers
Tuxedo Mask was but this other time she
was in a rush and she ended up pulling
open the bag and which she had was like
these straps so basically she had put
like make a suit out of these straps
like a bikini kind of thing just of
straps and then she put the back over a
head to hide like who she was because
she was really like revealing with just
straps you know covering just the
important areas so yeah that's pretty
cool no it's just I like I like like in
my parents are like females don't like
prepared to like give their all for
their male love interest and stuff I
really like that that's why I can't
stand some dress because yeah I mean
they just yeah you know like soon there
is no I've been like suitors are the
best no I agree with you in principle
so like so I like my girl albedo from
over again cuz [ __ ] whatever for her man
like in real life I tend to be attracted
to girl that end up being soon there is
I don't know why I don't know why I hate
yourself how about I oh no cozy girl and
horikita from a classroom of the elite
huh yep I agree I know probably soul and
a Mac heaven it's definitely one of the
better ones and you guys are missing out
so yeah I'm sorry I feel sorry for you
guys you're missing out somewhere
thought it was one of the better ones
but I don't know what do you agree for
me do you agree at least Tony katana
I don't know Corsica yeah okay uh would
you agree with me that for emo would you
have rather seen kills Kay end up with
her own echo from Orem oh yeah no I
would say his little sister what no no I
like the childhood friend and I loved
seeing the childhood friend Ken the
sister in bed yeah Luna said the anime
man X Aki and that is a canon anime
community ship so yeah definitely
quality ship what about Sol you might
get this reference no one else probably
will but what about ah Menma from yeah
yeah Patrick Swayze from ghost Oh No
how can you do that that's how order I
saw of order what do you mean Dean some
dirty dancing with Hinata xkv Yama from
high q-- Eromanga say sensei X thank you
for ignoring me okay yeah everyone say
recon actually liked it and I didn't
like it I I was like it was okay
basically the same thing as Oreimo well
I found Oreimo a lot more better than it
among the sensei even though it was
still even though it was still incest
but uh I really don't care
ha Shiro says all my eggs is it goes
wrong cannon already
pretty sure it is whose mom oh yeah i
early on I was getting those vibes bro
after all my I guess I don't want to get
into too many spoilers well I cannot
wait for the fight between all my baka
go and midoriya I cannot wait for that
oh yeah graduation
that's next episode that's thanks coming
up yeah and yeah that's the exam so like
though yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
afraid variks after that so hope they
hurry open air it and show it because
the next two arcs are so action-packed
and yeah yeah yeah those yeah those my
favorite um because it's like the event
of that arc leads directly into the
hockey I mean technically the school
trip arc and hideout ray dark well yeah
directly related yeah and then after
that is the hero license exam arc and
that was interesting too because we get
to meet a bunch of new characters from
different schools so yeah I actually
have a project in the works
regarding my rocket demon is gonna be
talking about some of these characters
coming this Saturday that's the plan and
we got another surprise big project in
the works as well so look out for that
some cool stuff and I'm mad can you make
a video about McCree the cowboy the
cowboy sniper can you make a video a lot
employee just looks like him from
[ __ ] overwatch to be honest yeah I
don't know we don't know much about
tonight yeah fun if you can make a video
about like you did for 13 oh yeah
they're not painful man you know have
enough info that when you start making
stuff up Oh gray eggs Julia that's a
good [ __ ] so Rika
why don't you tell me why you like Kate
likes also not so much
why not Kate or X any other generic girl
that is
because awesome is just better and I
know a lot of people are gonna say like
who seen on executors the best no I'm
not trying to copy you no never in a
million years
Kirito doesn't even like seen on doesn't
matter I ship it still he doesn't like
her I prefer asinine Kirito because they
were in it from day one going and nights
like not getting her own art they
weren't getting used to each other but
then later on they got married they got
a house they got Yui as a daughter and
yeah but what about Kirito ex random
girl that makes sores that we only
really seen the first arc and then she
completely fades into the back
Lizbeth know whatever Lisbeth no I don't
agree
I like Elizabeth II was cool to she's
playing the moon number two it's not
Elizabeth
it's Lizbeth Elizabeth was cool it's
gosh tough news my boy
brought up what interesting ship Hatsune
ma eggs that cool because yeah there is
the whole there is you know the hot
cement exec you shippers the you Erica
obstacle shippers the Suey wax that you
shippers and of course the true shippers
are toga X Deku that's me right here
baby
go oh yeah boom Oh crazy that cool plus
ultra baby plus ultra shipping right
there bloody so you need to just get
bloody yeah how come everybody came
shipping it right with I liked Todoroki
but I feel like he's good with Malmo so
yeah oh how about from dangan ronpa
kitty-kitty and Hinata oh no I ain't
seen that yet
I liked pin X ya know from kamini tada
cake I mean the main couple was nice as
well of course cuz you know they get the
most exposure but a vibe from ya know
with pin but then later in the manga
more comes into fruition you can more
see it well yeah yeah Phoenix a no
alright boys I think we all know what
it's time for
is it time to end the shipwreck ships no
no guys no soma well yeah I I did say
that the very beginning so my dough X
Luffy from one piece perfect what Mito
the girl that cooked meat yeah thanks
Luffy yeah we're not cross we're not
cross that's to stop [ __ ] cross
shipping it's weird to kasha
that's too weird why would you [ __ ]
put Luffy and the girl who cooks who
makes meat I know anything likes meat
yeah I know he likes me but this doesn't
work I'm not the only one who caught the
cold you weird I even sold it yeah no
yeah no it's just yeah it feels too weak
I think what it is is cuz Luffy is such
a strange kind of character to be
shifted someone who seems more
understandable yeah or normal is then
yeah it feels to whit yeah I mean it
just yeah yeah
romance though he just wants he wants me
to pick someone that would cook good
cook for him okay yeah I guess yeah I
guess on paper it makes sense I guess
yes how about some koi - oh so nojima
and Takasaki is that the main tooth yeah
make me - yeah you cut it yeah Lisbeth
so recon if you want to finally make
Lisbeth more than a pointless side
character there you go
she can be your wife no [ __ ] that man
pretty content Elizabeth no stop saying
Elizabeth not knowing when you get
things wrong caster for life knows me he
says Adam AK x Valletta X Colin yeah no
no no I not have an idea - Adam AK x me
me me go no but oh oh oh no oh no no no
the thing is reka no as soon as we start
cross shipping I just want to ship
myself with all the ladies I don't like
think about other animators like me X
all the sexy ladies okay who would you
ship yourself when me Oh Colin one one
oh come on man you got suited one man I
also say mine I've got a buy pillow man
where's your body pillow oh wait you
don't have one oh yeah well it's coming
bro Oh we'll see about that
you wanna have a body pillow war pillow
fight you and have a waifu pillow fight
your waifu vs my wife sorry I don't need
a body pillow
I share my missus and with my daughter
so it's on the way you can't you can't
talk about anime on YouTube without
having at least 8 to 9
that's what apparently the rule is so
well yeah
now that the recon has challenged me to
a pillow fight guys I think it's time to
wrap this baby up
thank you for watching tune in every
week we do this rag of a stuff every
week leave a like if you like rant cafe
and before we go I just want to
introduce everyone again kind of let
them tell you what they do who they are
starting with the anime dude why you
always go and start with me man
because the enemy dude I make character
analysis videos for the most part and I
occasionally do anime predictions on
upcoming seasons but another point I'm
primarily trying to focus on yes and
check out his channel link in the
description also caster said it aki 2x
Laila for Michael the Exile I like that
[ __ ] I like that trip a lot oh I guess
we'll go last three cons so soul maka no
I'll go I'll go no I'll go
ok ok usually you argue with me so go
ahead Rico alright how's it going boys
my name's Amerikan and I do reactions
and toptenz on my channel so if you
enjoy that type of content do check me
out and don't forget to [ __ ] smash
that subscribe button and that's it I
like how he was being all nice and play
and there's like [ __ ] smash smash
actually Briggs does that in Detroit
smash that like button
well you said [ __ ] smash it's too
late yeah the desperation already came
out after our discord link is in the
description we chat their voice channel
that was and soul maka knows because he
always organizes voice chats and keeps
that [ __ ] running my boy soul maka how
you been yeah yeah I'm good I'm good
yep you'll always catch me on a discord
I usually do voice chat sessions that
run from my I don't know seven eight
hours yes and when bleach is mentioned
in 9 to 10 hours yeah
no no well mainly recently we
been talking about like martial arts
manga Gundam series mainly you see
timeline and all the messed up her
Korean webtoons that have been coming
out but yeah I'm trying to work on my
channel I've got so many things I want
to do I need to do a corner a touchy
review and animate a manga comparison I
wanna do a video which is like a
beginner's guide to manga so loads of
different mangas that are like 50
chapters or less that I want to
recommend to get people just like
kick-started would Whedon some of them
are gonna be like 5 chapters or I'm like
well under 10 chapters I've also got a
visual novel I'm still trying to work on
I need to do the art and the music for
that as well as organize the story and
I'm also a hentai artist so I'm a very
busy man and I work so damn cut me some
slack okay I'll be done for my own thank
you again for joining me for always a
functional time here at rank of faith
thank everyone in the chat very good
contributions from the chat I gotta say
some hilarious hilarious ships my
favorite spill is Connor dou X dou dou
XK dojo yeah my favorite is reconyx
right hand recon X right hand
I'll take I'm sure I'm so that gives you
the false pleasure and sometimes the
body pills get involved you know it's a
good huh good Friday night good Nina X
table can still my favorite all-time
Sakina exhaling well guys thank you
again we will see you next week as
always and until next time see you space
cowboys coming we conquer I'll get you
for this